Hello, everyone.
And welcome to
lecture 4 of CME 296.
So before we start, I just want
to say that those first three
lectures were really
the most technical
and mathematically challenging.
So in that sense, I'm
still glad you're here.
And I really hope that those
three lectures gave you
the intuition as to why we were
going to use this generation
paradigm.
Because there are going
to be used as building
blocks for everything that
we're going to see from now on.
In particular, during
the first three lectures,
we focused on
unconditional generation.
And now, what we're
going to see is
how we can generate images
with a condition which
can be a user prompt, like
input text, or an input image.
And so in that sense, the
title of today's lecture
is multi-modal
guided generation.
With that, we're going to start.
And as usual, I'm
going to just recap
what we did the previous times.
So as I mentioned, the
first three lectures
were mathematically
challenging, and they
were about seeing
how we could generate
images, what were the
paradigms that we could use.
So the first lecture was focused
on the diffusion paradigm
with DDPM, where we saw that
we were taking clean images,
that we were noising
in a discrete way.
And so here, we
had this formula,
which was a combination of a
clean image and Gaussian noise
that we weighted with
those coefficients.
And what we saw
with a bunch of math
was that we could
derive an expression
that we could optimize
in order to reconstruct
those clean images
that we've noised.
And we ended up with a very
nice expression, an L2 loss
on the noise that was added.
And in particular, if
we wanted to denoise,
we had the following
formula that allowed you
to go from a step t to step
t minus 1 using this model e
theta, which was the predicted
noise that was added.
And so in that sense, it was
parameterized with respect
to the noise epsilon.
Then in lecture
2, what we did was
that we derived the continuous
version of what we derived
in a discrete way in lecture 1.
And we also saw a
second paradigm,
a second way of seeing things,
which was score matching.
And we saw that when
we looked at these two
ways of doing things, if we were
to take the increment of time
from t to t plus 1
and tend it to 0,
we had a general
expression of the increment
in x, which would be
as a function of dt,
the increment in
time, and dw, which
is the continuous
version of adding noise.
And in particular, you
had these two terms.
So on the left side, the drift
term, and then on the right side
was the diffusion term.
And we saw that in order
to reverse the noise that
was added, so a.k.a.
reverse process,
we could use a
result from theories
on stochastic
differential equations,
where we saw that we could
derive the reverse process if we
knew the score, which is
why this formulation was
parameterized as a
function of the score.
So here it's noted S of theta.
And in lecture three,
we saw that actually, we
could think of this whole
thing as a completely--
in a completely different way.
And we can think of it as
transporting a probability
mass from an
initial distribution
up to a target distribution.
And in that sense, we
could express a noisy image
as a combination
of noise and sample
from the target distribution.
And all of what we had
to do was to just predict
the vector field, a.k.a.
The velocity, which
was noted u of theta.
But one thing that
we kept silent
was how we could
actually represent
all of these quantities,
in particular xt,
the representation of the image
when it's noised at a given
level, the noise itself.
All of these, we just
assumed that there
was some way of
representing these in some n
or d dimensional space.
So one thing that
we will do today
is to see what
space could actually
be more appropriate
for this kind of work.
And then the second
thing is, as you can see,
the models that we need to
estimate-- so epsilon theta, s
of theta, you have theta.
There are only a function of
denoised image and the time,
but they're not a function of
any condition, any user input.
So this is also something that
we're going to see, a.k.a.
How can we incorporate
a condition
that could guide the generation
towards what we want.
So this is the menu for today.
So to recap, we're going
to see three things.
The first one is how can we
represent those noisy images.
The second thing that
we're going to see
is how to represent
the conditions
that we want as inputs.
So for instance,
the input text here,
a Teddy bear reading a book that
we want to generate an image for
or an input image that
you want to condition
your generation for.
And then the third thing is
how we can guide the generation
process using that as an input.
So we're going to
start with number one,
how to represent
these noisy images.
And I'm going to start with
the most natural approach
that you could have when
you see those images.
We, as humans, we are very
accustomed to seeing things
in the pixel space.
So here, if you take
this image as an example,
this image has a certain
height H, certain width, W.
So what you can do is
to represent each pixel
as a function of the intensity
of the color that composes it.
And in particular, a very
common representation
is using R, so red,
green, and blue.
So in other words,
you would have
each pixel that would
have three values, which
would make up the color.
And you would have these values
cover all pixels of the image.
So you would have
a dimension n that
would be equal to 3 times the
size, the number of pixels,
which is h times w.
And so you could
represent your image
as a tensor along the axis,
the height, the width,
and the number of
channels here, which
are three, which
represents R, G, and B.
So this could be one way.
But the big problem with that is
that it's very high dimension.
So if we take the example of a,
quote, unquote, "regular image,"
so 1,024 times 1,024 pixels,
then we would end up with
a number of dimensions,
which would be on the order
of a million.
So 10 to the power of 6.
And if you think
about it, this is just
a lot of dimensions to consider
in our training generation
paradigm algorithms,
which are, of course,
a function of the dimension
in which you operate.
So that's one very big drawback.
The second drawback is if
you look at your image,
you actually see that you
have a lot of redundancies.
So if you see, for instance, in
a given neighborhood of pixels,
you have a lot of
very similar values.
So in a sense, you can consider
this as a waste of dimensions.
So it's not very compact.
And then the third
thing is if you
remember our whole
first three lectures
were about taking the
image, and adding noise,
and then just moving it
in the space with respect
to added noise.
Well, here, if
you take an image,
and you were to move it
slightly in that space
by adding some noise,
you would actually
obtain an image, a noisy
image that would actually not
be very meaningful.
It would not mean anything.
So in particular, so
I'm not sure if you
recall this nice
graphs or charts, where
you would see the areas of
high density of your target
desired distribution.
So here, what we want is
clusters of observations
that are likely to occur.
But what we get is
actually the thing
on the right, which is a space
with very spiky regions, where
each spike represents
an actual valid image.
And that's not good.
So for all these
reasons, we're going
to just come up with
a wish list of a space
that we would like to have.
So I'm going to go
through that step by step.
So the first one is the high
dimensionality observation
that I made.
So here, what we want is a
dimension that's more, quote,
unquote, "tractable."
So that's number one.
Number two of our wish list is
to have a representation that
does not have a lot of
redundancies, that has
some way of compacting things.
So number 2 is compact
representation.
Number 3, regarding
the representation
not being meaningful,
so here, we
want a representation
that is meaningful.
And you can think of this when
I say what meaningful means.
It's when you look at
the space, and you're
able to have clusters of regions
where valid images happen.
That's what I mean
by meaningful space.
So this is our wish list.
So before we move ahead,
I want to take the time
to introduce two
terminologies that are widely
used in those papers.
So I prefer to define
them now and clearly
so that you what they refer to.
So you will see
that there is a lot
talk about semantic similarity.
So what does semantic
similarity mean?
So semantic
similarity of an image
is something that refers
to its global geometry
to its overall structure.
And in particular,
what that means
is if two images are
semantically similar,
what that means is
that they roughly
represent the same thing.
So here on the slide,
you have on the left
a Teddy bear that
is reading a book.
On the right, you
have also a Teddy bear
that is reading a book.
They're not exactly
aligned pixel wise,
but they're
semantically similar.
So that's for
semantic similarity.
Now, you have another notation,
which is perceptual similarity.
So this one refers to more of
the local details of an image.
More to the lower level
texture of an image.
And when you say that two images
are perceptually similar, what
that means is that to the
human eye, they look the same.
So for instance,
you have, again,
two pictures of a Teddy bear.
So I'm not sure if you
see the one on the right
has some little glasses.
But it's perceptually
very similar.
Does that make sense,
that distinction?
Yeah.
The reason why I say
that is I'm going
to use that terminology
going forward,
so I just want to make
sure we all what these are.
So what are we doing?
What we want is to come
up with a space that
fulfills our wish list
that we established before.
So here is our first attempt.
So how about we take an
image in the pixel space,
and what we try to do
is find a representation
that's meaningful using
the following architecture.
So let's assume we
take that image,
and we put it into some model.
Let's call it an encoder
that encodes the image
and produces an output
that is of lower
dimensionality as the input.
So here, we go from an
image of size HW and number
of channels, which,
as you know, is
equal to 3 in the pixel
space because in the RGB
representation.
And here, we end up with
a latent representation
of size lowercase h,
lowercase w, and little c.
And then what we do is we
put that representation back
to the decoder.
So if we were to do
that, our objective
is to recover the
original image.
So we don't want to
lose any information
by encoding our image into
a lower dimensional space.
So here, such a setup is
called an autoencoder.
So the only job
of an autoencoder
is to find a lower dimension
representation that's called
the latent representation.
And what it does
us is take an image
in the pixel space as input,
compress it, and then decode it.
And here, the task is making
sure that what you get as output
is the same as what
you get as input.
So you may think, OK, it's
a very useless model, which
I agree, unless you're
interested in the latent
space, which we are.
This is what we're
interested in.
So does this setup make sense?
Cool.
And then terminology wise, the
latent space, like that part,
is called the bottleneck just
because we're forcing the model
to rely on fewer
dimensions, and we
want the model to still preserve
the richness of the details that
are present in the image.
So let's see how we do that.
But before we go, I want to
introduce another notation
that you also see a
lot in papers, which
is called the spatial
compression ratio, which
is defined by the amount
by which you go from Big H
to little h.
So it's just the
ratio between the two.
And that ratio is typically
on the order of 8.
So that's the order of magnitude
that you should have in mind.
Cool.
So let's see now based
on what I told you
how each component works.
So in terms of what is input in
the encoder, as we mentioned,
we have our input image.
Let's note it x that we put in
our encoder, that we note E phi.
And we get a latent
representation z
that is equal to E phi of x.
And so the way we
would do that would
be to use a network that
contains some downsampling
operations.
So what that means is it
allows us to go from a bigger
dimension to a lower dimension.
We're not going to go
into too much details
into what that network is
because we're going to talk more
about this in the next lecture.
But I just want to tell you
roughly the two main operations
that you can expect,
which you may have seen.
So the first one
is convolutions.
So who has heard of
convolutions before?
Yeah, everyone.
So I can go fast.
Convolutions is just a way to
scan your image using a filter.
So the image is in red,
the filter is in blue.
And what you get is what we call
an activation map or a feature
map that is in purple.
And then the second
operation that you
see in these kinds of
networks is pooling.
So pooling is a
downsampling operator
that allows you to either take
the maximum of a given square,
or the average, or either max
pooling or average pooling.
And it allows you to introduce
some spatial invariance
just because you can aggregate
the pixels to a higher
granularity.
We're not going to go
into too much detail,
but these are just
for reference.
So when it comes to the
decoder, what you would do
is take the latent
representation
z into the decoder d theta.
And you would get your
reconstructed output x hat.
So here, you would use
upsampling operations,
for instance reverse
convolutions.
And the goal of this model
is as much as possible,
for your reconstructed
output to be as close as
possible to your input.
So the loss function
of such a model
would be something along the
lines of just an L2 regression
between the input x and the
reconstructed input x hat.
So I have a question for you.
Do you think this
model is a good model?
So this is what we're
going to see now.
So let's go through
our checklist.
First one is, OK., is the
dimension more tractable?
Yes, more tractable.
Is the representation
more compact?
Yes, it's more compact.
Is the representation
meaningful?
Meaning do you have a nice
shape in your latent space
in the way we represent it?
Yes, exactly.
Not necessarily.
Well, the reason for
that is we have not
constrained our latent
space to be structured
in any particular way.
So the model is just
only incentivized
to reconstruct the
input as best as it can.
And it really doesn't care
what shape the latent space is.
So you actually still
end up with this kind
of space, which is not good.
This is not good because
your flow matching model,
your diffusion model is just
not able to learn very well
in those spaces
because, first of all,
the representations
are all over the place.
And if you remember,
one common thing
with all of these
generation paradigms
is that you start from
a normal distribution,
like a standard
normal distribution.
So you need a way for
you to not get lost.
So if everything is far
apart, it just doesn't work.
So that's not good.
So let's go back to
the drawing board,
and let's see what
we can change.
So we take our image,
we compress it,
and then we decompress it.
Everything's perfect.
Well, let's see what we
can do in the latent space.
Our goal here would be to,
quote, unquote, "enforce"
the latent space to
have some structure.
So this is our goal.
And we're going to see
how we can do that.
OK, let's go back
to where we were.
We take our input image x.
But instead of just letting it
through a standard encoder, what
we will do is to actually
not try to predict
or generate the latent
representation directly.
We will actually predict
two things, the mean
and the standard deviation
of the distribution
that it can be drawn from.
So in other words, what we're
going to see to say is instead
of saying that one x corresponds
to one latent representation,
we're going to say that 1x
actually is mapped to some
probability distribution, which
sounds kind of weird, right?
It's not very natural.
But we're going to see why
that mitigates the problem.
So here, as a reminder, so
the output of the encoder
will not be just
a latent vector.
It will be-- so the mean mu phi.
And the variance
sigma squared phi.
So these are the two
outputs of the encoder.
And what we will say is that
the latent representation
of this distribution,
this latent representation
is actually drawn from
this distribution.
That's what we're going to say.
And we're going to
say something else.
So in a bit of an
informal way, we're
going to say that this
distribution is going
to be roughly forced to
follow or to approximate
another distribution.
So it's not very
mathematically rigorous.
We were going to see exactly
how we can express that.
But in your mind,
I want you to know
that this is a condition for
us to structure the latent
space in a way where
we say the latent
representation of an
input x will be roughly
in a given region of the space.
We're going to
force that, or we're
going to incentivize
the model to learn that.
So that's the idea.
Cool.
And yeah, this distribution is--
OK, you may have guessed it.
Again, standard normal
distribution just because it's.
It's a nice distribution
with great properties.
And by the way,
this distribution,
we're going to call it
the prior distribution.
So let's see how
the decoder works.
So let's assume we have put our
input image into the encoder.
We have predicted the mean.
We have predicted the
standard deviation.
We have drawn a
latent representation
from the distribution.
So now, the decoding
stage will be
around taking that
representation
and passing it through the
decoder which again will output
two things, the mean new theta
of this latent representation
z and standard deviation.
And what we're going
to say is, again,
that the reconstructed
image is going
to be drawn from a probability
distribution of these two
parameters.
Well, one thing that I
want to say is actually,
we're going to
simplify this part
of the problem a little bit.
We're actually going to say that
the variance is not something
we're going to predict.
We're just going to fix it to
be constant just because there
is less impact in you
making sure to introduce
some variation in the output.
Because in the pixel
space, even if you
add a little bit
of noise, it's not
going to change the
image a whole lot.
So that's why people
just say, OK, we're
going to take some variants
that's constant fixed,
and we're not going
to predict that.
We're only going to
predict the mean.
We can draw from
this distribution.
But sometimes, people also just
take the mean as the output.
So this part is
more of a detail.
Yeah.
So the question here is
that whether the latency
is drawn from the Gaussian
or is drawn from the q--
the encoder here
q phi z given x.
So it's a great question.
So this model, which we're
going to see what the name is,
is both a model that we can
use to learn the latent space,
And so have a
reconstruction task.
But it's also something
that can be interpreted
as a generative model.
So if your goal is to
reconstruct the input,
then your input here is
going to be the z that you
drew from that distribution.
So it's going to be the
latent representation of x.
But if your goal is to
generate just a new image,
then you would
actually draw that z
from the prior distribution.
So the question is the encoder
gives you a mean and a variance.
It does not give you something
deterministic exactly.
It gives you a mean
and a variance.
And what you're doing is
just drawing from that.
So you-- yes, you
draw from that.
So great question.
So the question is, well, if you
have a generative model here,
why would you bother.
And just use diffusion, use flow
matching, use all these things?
It's a great question.
You have a number of
differences between the two
which makes diffusion flow
matching and score actually
perform better than VAE.
One of the differences is
here, you only go from latent
to pixel in just one step,
whereas the other ones,
you have several steps
that just allows you
to put more compute in there.
That's one reason.
But there are some
others that I hope we
can get to if we get some time.
But we're going to see the
relationship between the two.
Another question?
Yeah.
The question is,
does the latent space
look like a normal distribution?
So there is something that makes
it be "regularized," quote,
unquote, to be a
normal distribution.
It depends on a
term that you can
tweak with respect
to a coefficient
that we're going to see.
And depending on the
value of that coefficient,
it may look more or less
than a normal distribution.
But we're going to see that.
Cool.
So the first time I saw
this model, I was confused.
You may be confused
now, and I hope
what we're going to see will
make you a bit less confused.
So here, one thing
that I want to say
is in the autoencoder case, the
loss function was pretty clear.
You would just try to estimate
the reconstructed output
in such a way that it's as
close as possible to your input.
But here, you have a bunch
of distributions everywhere.
There's not like an obvious
way of expressing that
without doing some math.
So what I propose is that
we derive the loss function
for this model, which I'm not
sure if I can tell it now,
but I'm going to tell it.
It's called the
variational autoencoder.
And we're going to see
what makes it variational.
So if you remember,
in a lot of cases,
the way you derive
a loss function
is by doing maximum
likelihood estimation.
So what does that mean?
That means that you have some
model of parameters theta.
And what you want is to find
the parameters theta that
maximize the probability of
your model seeing the data.
That's what ML is.
And that's what
we're going to use
to see how we can derive
a loss function that
can help us learn theta.
So in particular, what
we want is to maximize
the log of p theta of x.
So I'm going to write it down.
So what we want is to express
log p theta of x with respect
to something that
we can compute.
Because this, we cannot
really compute something just
by looking at it.
So let's see how we can do that.
So I'm going to just start
with expressing p theta of x
as a function of something.
So this model can be seen
as a generative model that
starts from a latent variable
that you draw from what
we call a prior distribution.
So one idea of
expressing p theta
of x, if you remember
lecture 1, we can consider
the joint probability
distribution of p theta
of z, a latent, and x, and
sum across all latent z
that led to x.
We can do that, right?
So what we say is
that p theta of x
is equal to this
joint probability
distribution of x, your image in
pixel space, and z, your latent.
And you're just going
to integrate over
all possible latent
representations.
So this quantity is
nothing else than you're
drawing from a prior, so p of
z, and then using your decoder
to estimate x given z.
So this quantity is the
integral of your prior times
p theta of x given z, dz.
P of z.
Yeah, exactly.
So the Gaussian.
p theta x given z.
Well, it's your model, your
model that you want to find.
The problem is that
you need to compute
this for all possible latent z.
And z is still
high dimensional--
high dimensional vector.
So this, if you were to compute
this quantity for all z,
it's actually not
something that you can do.
Because you would have to
compute a lot of such quantities
with given zs in order
to get a good estimate.
And it's just not
something that you can do.
So do you remember a similar
setting we had in lecture 1,
which is the reason
why we're going
to see how we can find
a convenient bound that
could be maybe more tractable?
Because so far, I
have not used the fact
that we also have a way to
encode the input in order
to get latents that are
more likely to be the ones
that I want to consider here.
So what I'm going to
do now is to find--
so what I want to do first
is to maximize this quantity.
So I want to find theta that
maximizes this quantity.
So we saw just now that this
quantity is not something
that I can actually compute.
So what we're going
to do is to find
a lower bound that
could be something
that you could compute.
And what we want to do is
to maximize that lower bound
in the hope that it will
also maximize this in order
to find our parameters theta.
So let's do it.
So you would have the following.
So I'm going to just come here.
I would just say that p of x
is equal to the integral of p
of z times p theta of x given
z, which is just at that point,
I'm going to use the
same trick that we
did in lecture 1,
which is to involve
the output of the encoder.
And here, it is q phi of z given
x times q phi of z given x.
So what does this represent?
So this represents the
probability distribution
of the zs that are likely
to occur for this given x.
Because here, in the original
form, what you were doing
was to just sum across all
possible latent representations
out there, but there
are many of them.
So it's like,
you're in the ocean,
and someone tells you, OK, just
look through the whole ocean.
But the thing is, only
a small subset of the zs
are actually the
ones that you want.
They're actually only
a subset of the zs that
are the ones that are
responsible for your x
to appear, which is the reason
why we're letting these q
phi of z given x pop up.
And this expression, so
this is equal to this.
And this gets equal to just
the expectation of p of z times
p theta of x given
z over q phi of z
given x, where your z is
drawn from q phi of z given x.
So why am I doing
this whole thing?
Because what I want
to do is to take
the log of this whole thing.
I want to take the log
of this whole thing
and do the same trick as
we did for the DPM, which
is the Jensen's inequality.
And I'm going to say
that it's the expectation
of the log of this whole thing.
So I'm taking the log of this
quantity, which I expressed
as a function of the output
given by the encoder for which I
can find a lower bound.
And now, we're going to see that
this lower bound is actually
something that is tractable.
We're going to see it now.
So what I'm going to do is to
just rewrite this expression.
So we have-- so the expectation
of the log of the whole thing,
which is equal to the
expectation of the log of p
theta of x given z plus
the expectation of--
so I'm going to be
a little bit smart.
I will say minus the expectation
of the log of q phi of z
given x over your
prior distribution.
So here, what I
just did was I take
the log of pz times p theta of x
given z over q phi of z given x.
And what I did is I just--
I used the property
of the log, which
is logarithm of the
product, is the sum
of the logarithm of the terms.
So I had this one pop up.
And this one, I just rearranged.
I put the denominator
in the numerator,
and I added the minus.
And given that it's an
expectation for both
of these that are over z drawn
from your encoder output, which
is q phi of z given x,
this term is actually
the KL divergence of q phi
of z given x and your prior.
So what does this all mean?
What this all means
is in order to find
the theta that
maximizes this quantity,
we derived a lower bound.
That is something that
will see is tractable.
So it's this expression, which
we have divided into two terms.
So the first one is
expectation of the logarithm
of p theta of x given z.
And the other one
is a KL divergence.
So we're going to see that
these two terms are actually
quite interpretable.
The first one is actually
a reconstruction term.
Because if you remember,
p theta of x given z
is a normal distribution
with fixed variance.
So we know the probability
density analytically.
So if you take the
log of the probability
density of a Gaussian,
you actually end up
with something super simple,
which is the norm of x.
So the input and the
reconstructed outputs.
And then the second
term is actually a term.
So back to your question.
It is a term that penalizes
the distribution coming
from your encoder being far from
this fixed prior distribution.
So loss functions usually
have a coefficient
in front of this
term to penalize
more or less the fact
of being far or close
from this prior distribution.
And depending on the
coefficient there,
you're going to have
either something that
will look like a normal
distribution or not.
So that is the part of your loss
that will allow you to do that.
I'm looking at the time.
I'm not super in
advance, but I'm
going to just pause
for one minute
if you have any questions.
So the question is we're pushing
the distribution of the encoder
to be more of the
normal distribution.
So we want to do that to
normalize the latent space,
but we don't want
to do that too much.
Otherwise, so the prior
distribution is p of z.
It doesn't care what x is.
And in other words, if you push
it too much towards something
that is just static,
it will just not
consider the input at all.
It will collapse.
Yeah, so it's called
posterior collapse.
So just one other question,
and then I'll move on.
Yeah.
So the question is--
so we had this image
with the little
spikiness and that
was the autoencoder, the
standard autoencoder part.
This one is actually structured
in the latent space in a way
that makes it more smooth, more
well put together, and yes.
So I'm going to speed
up a little bit.
Let's go through our checklist.
Tractable dimension, yes.
Compact representation, yes.
Meaningful representation, yes.
Oops, truthful representation.
No.
Wait.
Why is that?
So these models, they actually
end up reconstructing the image
in an imperfect way.
And what we actually obtain
are more blurry images.
And so I'm hoping that
in the next nine minutes,
we're going to see
why that is the case
and how we can solve it.
So first of all,
let's look at the loss
function that we
have derived, which
is composed of a reconstruction
loss and a regularization loss.
So the reconstruction loss.
What is it?
We have not derived it here.
But I am telling you
that if you derive it,
it is the pixel wise
L2 between the input
and the reconstructed output,
the reconstructed input, sorry.
And so what that means is if the
generation is a little bit off
by a few pixels, it will
actually get very penalized.
Because the distance
is pixel wise.
So what ends up
happening is the model
tends to produce values
that are more averaged,
which produces this blurriness
sensation that you're seeing.
But then you will tell me, well,
Afshin, the standard autoencoder
also had that loss.
So why didn't it happen there?
Well, the fact is, it
also happened there,
but it's even more
pronounced here
because of the structure of
the model that we have defined,
which is that the latent
representation is not
a one to one mapping with
the input x, it is not.
Instead, what we have
said is a given input x
maps to a probability
distribution,
like a set of
probable points that
could be actually latent
representations of this x.
So the model will
introduce this uncertainty
even more in the reconstruction
that it will output.
And here, what we want
to do is to combat
that blurriness sensation.
Because here, if we were to
perform diffusion in the latent
space, and if we were to decode
the final output in the latent
space, the last
thing that we want
is for our output to be blurry.
We do not want that.
So now, we're going to
see a couple of strategies
that will allow us to combat
that blurriness artifact
that we're seeing.
And the first one is going to
be about a kind of loss that's
called the perceptual loss.
I'm going to say
exactly what that means.
So let's imagine you
have your image x.
The intuition here is we don't
want the reconstructed output
to be compared with
the input pixel
to pixel because it does not
allow for little shifting
here and there.
So what we want instead is to
be able to compare the input
and the reconstruction
more in terms
of similarity, that something
that looks similar to you
as a human,
perceptually similar.
So how can you do that?
Well, there are some
models out there
that there are convolutional
based, for instance,
that actually extract
features from these images
in their layers.
And here, we refer
them as feature maps.
And one good thing-- one good
thing about these feature maps
is that they represent
things from this image that
have more of a
spatial invariance
compared to the original image.
So what does that mean?
That means that if you have
two images that are slightly
shifted, slightly
different, then
their feature maps will
actually not be that different.
So the idea here is instead
of comparing the pixel based
images one to the
other, we're going
to compare their representation,
their feature maps
one to another.
And I'm not sure if
you've heard that loss,
but there is a loss
that's called LPIPS, so
Learn Perceptual Image
Patch Similarity.
So it is a loss or it is
a metric I should say,
that is composed of the
difference between the feature
maps of two images, and that are
weighted by a coefficient, which
is here WL.
There are coefficients
that are tuned
by the authors of
this paper in order
to match what humans consider
as being perceptually similar.
So long story short-- so by
the way, the formula is scary,
but it's not that big of a deal.
We don't care about
the whole thing.
What we care about is
that we're not comparing
images in the pixel space.
We're comparing images
between their feature maps.
And what we're saying here
is that the feature maps
of two images better reflect
their structure, their details,
and are less sensitive
to spatial differences.
So that is one strategy.
So one thing to note is that
we would weight this loss
by some coefficients.
You could think, OK, this loss
is answering all our needs.
Let's have the weight for this
part of the loss be super high.
Well, if you do
that, actually, there
are some bad things
that also happen.
So we have what we call
checkerboard artifacts, which
as you can tell is like
a grid like artifact
in the image that is
similar to this one.
So you don't want to have
too big of a weight either.
So that's one.
And then a second strategy
to combat blurriness
is what we're going to see now.
So the problem that we have
is that the decoder of the VA
is outputting an
image that is blurry.
So one idea could be
to ask another model
to tell you whether
the input image, so
in this case, the blurry
image is a real image or not?
And based on that,
what we would do
is incentivize this
other network called
the discriminator, to
distinguish outputs coming
from the decoder compared to
real images, which would then
flag blurry images
as being fake.
And we would
penalize the decoder
for generating images
that would be flagged
as fake by the discriminator.
So have you heard
of GANs before?
So we don't have time to
talk about them in detail,
but I think this slide is
summing up what is happening.
So you have two models that
are competing with one another.
The decoder that wants
to produce images that
the discriminator cannot
distinguish from being fake,
and the discriminator that wants
to distinguish the output from
the decoder compared to
images from real life.
And what this will
do is incentivize
the decoder to produce
more realistic images.
And in doing so, it will help
with removing that blurriness.
So that is called
adversarial loss.
So what we saw was that the
original loss of the VA,
which we derived here, led to
outputs that were too blurry.
It was fulfilling all the
wish list that we had,
but it was not leading to a
truthful reconstruction, which
is the reason why we saw
two different strategies
to add to our loss,
to counterbalance
the tendency for the model
to produce blurry outputs.
So these are the perceptual
loss and the adversarial loss.
So before giving
it to Sherwin, I
could not let you
without telling you
how this fits together
with the diffusion models.
So in particular, the reason
why we did this whole thing
is for us to use our
diffusion flow matching
model not in the pixel space,
but in the latent space.
Because computationally
it's just cheaper
and it's able to scale.
So now, we're going to see
what our strategy for training
and inference is.
So for training, what
we do is we first train
the VA exactly like we saw.
And then what we're going to do
is to train our image generation
model, like using for
instance flow matching,
in the latent space of the VA.
And we're going to
see how we do that.
So let's suppose we have an
image from our target data
distribution.
We pass it through the encoder.
Our encoder gives
us two quantities.
So the mean and the
standard deviation.
And what we do is we sample
from that distribution
to get our latent
representation.
And then what happens
is in our latent space,
so we hopefully have a
smoother latent space.
We have our z1, which
corresponds to the clean image.
We sample from the
noisy data distribution.
And here, I'm just illustrating
the case of flow matching,
we have zt, which is a weighted
combination of the two.
And what we do is we
optimize for, let's say,
our velocity like the l2 loss.
We'll do that.
This is for training.
So how about inference?
Well, let's assume that you
have trained your model.
Then now, what you want to
do is to generate new images.
So what you're going to
do is to first sample
from an easy distribution
in the latent space.
So for instance, Gaussian noise.
And you're going to
use, for instance flow
matching, the velocity
that you have learned
to solve it numerically and
arrive, at let's say a point
z1, which is the latent
representation of your end
trajectory.
And what we're going
to do is to use
the VAE decoder to decode that
output back to pixel space.
So let's see how it looks like.
So this is your latent
space that you have learned.
You sample from the
noisy distribution
in that latent space.
You solve numerically the ODE
using the learned vector fields
that we've trained right before.
You obtain z1.
The problem is, z1 to us,
it doesn't mean anything
because it's not
in a pixel space.
So what you do is
you take that z1,
you pass it through the
decoder, and you obtain
the image in pixel space.
So to conclude, what
we've seen is a way
to find a latent space that
is of lower dimension, that
is smoother, and that
is also able to preserve
the details of your image.
And so in particular,
we say that the encoder
acts as a low pass filter.
Because what it does represents
those images mostly based
on their semantic similarity.
So this is actually
something we have not seen.
But for a diffusion model
to find all the details
in its exploration
is much harder
than finding something
that is semantically
what it wants to generate.
So this is the reason why
we're giving the decoder
the task of conveying all
the low level details, all
the perceptual elements.
And the role of the decoder
is to take that latent
representation and to
make it an output that
is full of details,
that is realistic,
and that is matching
what we want.
And for that reason,
you have the encoder
and the decoder, which you
would think is symmetric.
But in practice, the VAEs
that are used in conjunction
with diffusion models are such
that the decoder is actually
bigger than the encoder.
Does that make sense?
So we don't have a lot of time.
So one thing that
I put down there
is a longer form
version of everything
I mentioned in some very
interesting articles, which
I recommend reading,
but not mandatory
as part of this class, which is
some results from flux 2, which
is a text to image model,
and the LDM paper, the Latent
Diffusion Model paper that is
at the bottom of the slide.
Yeah.
So the question
is, what should we
think of the role of the
encoder and the decoder?
So at the end of
the day, what you
want is to have an easy
time generating images,
at the end of the day.
And what you want is
to not have too high
of a computational burden for
your diffusion model to operate.
So what you want
is a latent space
that is low in dimensionality,
and that is easy for you
to learn.
So what does easy for
you to learn mean?
It means having a space
that is not super spiky,
but that is more smooth.
And in particular, in order
for you to obtain such a space,
it is actually something
that in practice, something
that you can obtain if you
focus on the semantic meaning
of these images, as opposed
to capturing all the low level
details.
So in other words,
what I'm saying
is, even if two images are
perceptually not very similar,
but if they represent
the same thing,
what we want for these images
is to be located not too
far from one another
in the latent space.
So we want the encoder to mostly
capture the semantic meaning.
So the encoder, what we want is
to make the job of the diffusion
model easy.
And so this is the learnability.
You will see in those
paper, learnability.
So once you have images that
are semantically similar,
that are close to one another,
you do your diffusion process.
You obtain, let's say
a point that you say,
OK, this is the
latent representation
that I want to have
in the pixel space.
So now, the job
of your decoder is
to make sure that all the
details that you want to have
in this final image are there.
So in that sense, in
contrast to the encoder,
the decoders job is to make sure
all the perceptual details are
present in the final decoded
image in the pixel space.
So in that sense, you have
these two different roles
of the encoder and the decoder.
So you want your diffusion model
to have an easy time learning
this thing, and you
want a space that
has some semantic
information, which is what
I mentioned the encoder can do.
But what you want, at
the end of the day,
is to have an image that
contains the details that you
want, and that part
is mostly something
that decoder can help with
in the decoding stage.
OK, I'm 10 minutes over
time, but with that, I'll
give it to Sherwin.
Thank you, Afshin.
So now, we're going
to see together
how to represent the
conditions that we
have at the input of
this generation models.
So the first kind of
condition that we can have
is the text one.
So the text world, when it
comes to representing embeddings
has a long history.
And I'm not going to go through
the whole history of how
we represent embeddings.
I'm just going to focus
on how people do it today.
And the way they do it is with
transformer-based architectures.
So let's first see how we can
decompose the input sentence.
So we have this concept
called tokenization,
which is the practice of
decomposing any piece of text
into atomic components.
So you can have
something that operates
at an arbitrary level,
word level, subword level
or character level.
And a software level
is usually algorithms
that learn how to best decompose
the tokens with respect
to the data by
focusing a vocabulary
budget on those tokens
that most frequently occur.
And the tokenization technique
that's most used these days
is subword.
But for simplicity,
the one that you're
going to see in the slides
is more towards arbitrary,
but it's just for
representation purposes.
So who knows about transformers?
OK, so most of you.
So there is a sister
course that talks
about transformers at length.
I'm not going to talk about
transformers at length,
but just give the main
pieces of information
that you should know.
So it is an encoder,
decoder architecture
that is centered on the
concept of extension.
And it came out in 2017.
And most of the language
models that you see today
are based off of it.
Even vision models,
you have many of them
that are based on
the transformer.
And the good thing about
it that made it work well
is that it's
inductive biases are
based on the concept
of attention that
proved to be generalizable.
And let's focus now on
this concept of attention.
So if we had to summarize in
a single sentence what it is,
it is the practice
of representing
a given piece of input as a
function of all the others.
And here, with the
example, a cute Teddy bear
is reading, if we
want to represent
in the space of
attention the token Teddy
bear, what we do is that we have
embeddings for all these tokens.
You have learnable matrices
that will turn them
into the space of queries,
q, keys, k, and values, v.
And what you're going to learn
is a distribution of keys--
of this key over keys.
And the weights
that you obtain are
going to be those that you place
on the corresponding values.
So in summary, you're able to
represent the embedding of Teddy
bear with respect to the others
in this sentence in that way.
And you can write this
down in matrix form, which
is this softmax term that
represents this probability
distribution.
So the square root of
DK is just a normalizing
constant that prevents the
sum from becoming too large.
So the dimension of
these queries and keys.
And multiplied by the
value, which carries
the embedding of the values.
So you can find
this attention layer
at three different locations.
So two of them are
self-attention layers.
So in the encoder
and another one
masked self-attention,
which conveys the fact
that tokens can
attend only on those
that were predicted before.
And then you have another
layer, where attention occurs,
which is called cross
attention, which
will make these queries
attend on other encoded keys
and values.
So this is the high level.
And in just a few words,
the main components
is that your input tokens
are converted into embeddings
with a learnable layer.
You add some
information regarding
the position of your tokens.
Then you make it through or
go through an encoder that
will apply this
concept of attention
and also add on top of it
some learnable mechanism
to add some complexity for each
tokens representation, which
is those feedforward network.
And then the decoder level,
when you want to generate,
let's say a sentence, you start
with some placeholder token
that you--
for which you add position
embeddings as well,
that you self-attention
and then perform
cross-attention with respect
to your encoders tokens.
And then you also
have feedforward there
to finally obtain your output.
So I'm telling you
all that to mention
that there are locations where
embeddings can be extracted out
of all of these.
So if you use the encoder
part of the network,
you can find the ends of the
encoders, a location where
you have an encoded meaning
of your inputs tokens.
And this is typically
one of those locations,
where you could say these are
the embeddings of my input.
OK, great.
So now, doing the
same for images.
Let's say you have a condition
that is based on images.
One thing that is pretty
nice is that everything
that we mentioned just now
can be reproduced with images.
So all these token
representations
are just numbers.
And you could well
represent these numbers.
You can associate them
with patches of images.
And this is what the ViT vision
transformer paper does, which
follows the same principle.
But instead of learning
embeddings on tokens,
you learn embeddings of
on patches of images.
So everything stays the same.
And you can perform tasks, such
as image classification with it.
And something that I haven't
done in the tech space
that we can do here together
in this image world,
is to see how these
pieces come together
in this example of a
Teddy bear reading a book.
So here, you decompose your
image into these patches
that we mentioned.
Each of these patches,
you have a learnable layer
that gives you an initial
representation of what
they mean.
So in the case of
text, you would
have a dictionary of tokens
that are mapped to embeddings.
But here, you have something
that is more continuous.
So you can have a linear layer.
You can have a
convolutional layer.
You can have
everything you want.
So you have something
at that stage
that gives a representation
of these patches.
And then in a classification
setting, you have a token.
So for example here, CLS
that will carry information
regarding the class of your
image that you want to predict.
So each of these can be
represented by embeddings.
And we mentioned that we have
position information encoded
in them.
And next class, we're going to
see more about position encoding
and all of this.
So I'm not going
to expand too much.
So you have a
representation for each
of these patches of your input
that you then feed your VIT.
And exactly, as we mentioned,
at the output of the encoder,
you can locate one
specific embedding
that carries the semantic
information of your input image.
So here, it would be the output
corresponding to the CLS token
that here, you project
to learn a classification
task for example.
But let's say you are
at a representation
stage of your workflow.
You would just
take the embedding
that you see in orange at the
top as your representation
of the image.
OK, great.
So something that I didn't
tell you is that for texts,
doing that process
is cheap in data
because the task that we
use to learn these models
is self-supervised by nature.
We anchor on next token
prediction in the world of text,
and you have a bunch of
text in the internet.
It's easy to have such data,
and it's easy to learn.
But in the image
world, if you want
to handcraft a similar task
that is as meaningful as what
we have in the text world,
we have a bit more trouble.
One of these candidates
that I just shown
is the classification task,
for example, for which you
need to gather labels.
So it's quite expensive.
And I just want to say
that one follow up work
that works on embedding
of images that we're not
going to see in details today
is Dino self-distillation
with no Labels for
which the concept is
to have a teacher and a
student model that receive
the different kinds of inputs.
And they aim at learning
similar probability distribution
in the output that
are prototypes.
So I think it's a
very interesting paper
to see how we can
build representations
out of no labels, just out
of the images themselves.
So OK.
Great.
So now, we went through how we
can represent text and images.
So did everything
make sense so far?
So we went slightly
fast, but I just
want to make sure we
got the gist out of it.
Yeah, the comment is
in the image world.
Do these images
become tokenized?
So you can think
of them that way.
The only difference
is that we don't
have a dictionary of tokens,
but rather we look at them
in a continuous manner.
Because in the text world,
you would just have a lookup.
But here, a learnable.
So that's exactly right.
Yeah.
So the comment is depending
on how you cut your image,
you can have errors.
Yeah, totally right.
And this is why it's
a hyperparameter.
This ViT model comes with
different batch sizes,
and this is one
of the trade offs.
Yeah, so I mean, absolutely.
OK, awesome.
So now that we have seen how
to represent text and images
separately, you might
wonder, OK, hey,
I want to generate a new
image with conditioning.
That depends on
both, let's say, were
I want to condition
on either, but I
don't want to have to
deal with two spaces.
So how would you
bring them together?
So what we want is to learn
a relationship between text
and image that has this nice
property of when you look
at the embedding space,
you want similar concepts,
either image text to
be grouped together,
and dissimilar ones
to be pushed away
from each other with
respect to some metric.
So let's take the
example of our Teddy bear
and something totally unrelated.
Let's say a water polo ball.
So the Teddy bear with the text
token, Teddy bear is similar.
Same with the water polo ball
image and the water polo ball
token.
But the opposite pairs are nuts.
And we want a way to
quantify each situation
and learn it automatically.
So how can we do that?
So let's build a
matrix of these two.
So this is just phrasing
in a different way What.
I've just said.
And what we want is Teddy
bear and the image of Teddy
bear to be of high similarity.
So what we're going to do
is project these embeddings
that we talked about
in the same space.
So we're going to build these
vectors with the representations
that we just saw before.
So what we're doing
here is the same.
So we have our patches of
images alongside the CLS token
that you pass through
the VIT architecture.
And then once you get the
last embedding representation,
what we're going to do is
to project it in a space
that we're going to have it
shared with the tech space.
So the property of that
projection layer that we built
is that it's going to output
a vector of same dimension
by construction as
the one for text.
So we do that here.
And then we do the same
for the text world.
So by the way, I
mentioned to you
that we would look at embeddings
at the end of the encoder layer.
And here, I'm showing
another procedure
to get embeddings of text, which
is to pass all of these tokens
to the decoder and decode
the one corresponding
to the last token.
And by construction of
the attention mechanism
and the transformer,
these embedding
coming out of the
last token is going
to represent the whole sentence.
So it's another
equivalent way of showing
the representation of tokens.
And we're going to take that
representation and project it,
as we said, in that
same shared space.
And by construction, these
u and v are now comparable.
You can do dot products.
You can compute similarities.
And we define these
similarity S variable
that is the scaled dot product.
And one thing that
we can do now is
to transform this
notion of similarity
into some score that can be seen
as a probability distribution
through the softmax operator.
So if you compute the
exponential of the similarity
between image Teddy
bear and Teddy
bear over the sum of the
exponentials of this image Teddy
bear and all the
other text tokens,
you find the
probability distribution
that this image corresponds
to that piece of text.
So you can do that from a fixed
image to the set of texts.
And you can do that
on the other hand,
with a fixed piece of text
token to all the images.
So you can have both ways.
And what we do is that we
can define two losses that
look symmetric, that represents
respectively, how similar,
like the penalization of any
error of a fixed image based
on all pieces of
text and similarity
error of a piece of text with
respect to all the images.
So it's symmetric cross entropy.
And then when we sum
these two losses,
we can obtain a final
formulation that
represents what we care about.
So that is the key
of the CLIP model
that trains the representations
of both image and text worlds
into, like with this
way of training things.
So what we do is that we
scrape a bunch of images
and captions off
of the internet.
And then for a
given batch, we say
that a given image
has its associated
caption as the true
label, and then
all the other captions in
that batch are negatives.
So it's called in
batch negatives.
And you do the same thing
of captions with respect
to all the images.
And you obtain that way final
embeddings in the text and image
encoders here that will generate
the representation that you're
looking for.
So here, just to give
some order of magnitude,
the paper talked about
400M pairs of data.
And it's great
reach great accuracy
even unsupervised tasks.
But the issue here
is this softmax.
So every time you have
a huge batch of data,
you need to build a similarity
matrix of a fixed image
with respect to all the
captions and symmetrically.
And this is not a
great computationally.
And also, from a
mining standpoint,
what you're truly
saying in your loss is
that you want to maximize the
similarity of your true image
caption pair, but you don't
it's truly enforce the fact
that all the other similarities
should be each very small.
So some follow up work reframes
this problem into a sigmoid loss
one.
So instead of saying I want this
one image to have a probability
distribution that matches
that of the true caption,
we take one caption and
one image separately,
and we ask ourselves the
question, do they match or not?
And by doing so you don't have
all this similarity matrix
complexities.
And also, you have a stronger
statement at your loss level
that's pushes the positives
together and the negatives
further apart.
OK, so any questions on this
contrastive learning part?
Yep?
The question is, do you start
from a pre-trained encoder,
and what weights do you change?
So I think in the paper,
they start from scratch.
And they train both
encoders from scratch.
You could very well
freeze or start
with some pre-trained encoder.
Freeze all the layers.
Let the last layer.
I think typically, you
would just train everything.
And in real life, I think you
just wouldn't train anything.
You would just pick something
out of Hugging Face.
But yeah, in
practice, since it's
easy to get all this
data-- so typically,
you would scrape the internet.
Look at images, and look
at all tags in HTML.
So you can get all these pairs.
So I think you're
in such a setup,
where doing it from
scratch makes sense,
but what you suggested
makes sense as well.
Yeah.
So I think it depends
on what works best.
Yeah.
So the question is the
transformer architecture
a prerequisite for this task.
Not at all.
So you can do it
with any encoders.
And the reason why I
talked about transformers
is to ground the way of encoding
into what people do in practice.
But you don't have to have this
architecture as a prerequisite.
Yeah.
OK, awesome.
So now, we're going to
reach the most exciting part
of the class, which is finally,
how do you guide our generation
model with the condition.
And we're going to go back to
thinking about what we discussed
these past lectures.
So we had this
diffusion mechanism,
where you are at a given
step here, xt plus 1.
And you want to find the less
noisy version of the image xt.
And the thing that
we want to do now
is to do that with a
condition that I called y,
but that you might see
called c in papers.
So you want to guide the
generation towards generating
a sample that follows y.
So a first idea that
you might have is OK,
it's a classification.
There is a concept
of classification.
I can come up with a
classifier of weights phi
and try to make it work.
So how could you make it work?
You start from this
probability distribution
that you want to sample from.
And then by applying
Bayes' rule,
like the conditional version
with the right arguments
for A, B, and C, you obtain
this product of two probability
distributions that you
can see on the left
represents the one step
generation process that we know.
And on the right side, you have
the probability distribution
of y given xt, which
would typically be what
the classifier would give you.
So now, let's see how we
could sample from this.
So taking a look at the
probability distribution
on the left.
So if we recall
the first lecture,
let's say in the DDPM world,
you know that this probability
distribution follows a
normal distribution of a mean
that we learn and
of variance that
is following a noise schedule.
So we don't learn it.
It's something that we have.
So we know the
expression of this.
If you look at the probability
distribution of this,
it's something that we know.
So we have that on one hand.
And on the other, we look at
our probability distribution
at the end of the classifier.
So here, why are we
not happy with that--
I mean, we have the data of
the probability distribution.
You just have to put the noisy
image to your classifier,
and then you have it.
You have a probability
distribution.
Why are we not happy with that?
It's because we cannot plug it
into that product equation that
we saw and then
easily sample from it.
We want to reframe
it in a way that we
can have this nice Gaussian
distribution that we
had, for example, at the
unconditioned generation step.
So what we do is that
we have a trick that
expands this probability
distribution with a Taylor
expansion.
And then you come
up with a first term
that is a function of xt.
And when you plug
the probability,
I mean the log of p phi that we
just found into this product,
you see that the
probability distribution
that you want to learn is simply
the same one that you had,
but with a shifted mean.
So I just want to take
a pause for a second.
So we went through
a process that where
we tried to find
an easy probability
distribution to sample from.
So we went through a
series of equations.
But all I want you to
know from all of that
is that we tried to get
to this state, where
we can sample from
an easy distribution,
and that's what we reached.
So in some way, we're happy.
And then here,
what's good about it
is that you don't
need to retrain
your unconditioned model.
So your theta and your
sigma t are things that.
And there is a downside to it.
Now, I mentioned classifiers.
You need to learn a classifier
that operates on noisy images.
And the process here
is that you need
to have that classifier that
predicts some probability
distribution, and then you
need to take the backward pass
on the network in order
to find the gradient.
Did that make sense so far?
OK, great.
So when we sample
from the distribution
that I mentioned in practice,
one thing that people see
is that it doesn't
produce samples that
follow the y condition enough.
So this is why you see that
W factor being introduced
that can be tuned to
force the generation
process to follow the
classifier's gradients more.
And this is what we
call the guidance part.
So we saw that we
don't have to retrain
the unconditioned model
in order to sample
from this distribution.
But on the other hand, you
need to have a classifier that
operates on top of a domain that
can be composed of noisy images.
And the bad thing about
it is that you typically
don't have that out of the box.
So it's typically
something that you
have to train as part of
your training process,
which is a downside.
And also, the fact that you need
to compute the backwards pass
of your classifier
is quite expensive,
which is also not great.
And something else
that I will mention
is that you not only need to
have that extra classifier
and spend all these budgets
to compute the gradients,
but you need to make sure that
the signal of your gradients
scales well with the coefficient
w that you introduce.
So you need some
hyperparameter tuning
to make sure that the operation
that you're doing is meaningful.
So one question that
you might ask yourself,
is it possible to do this guided
generation without the needs
of a classifier?
And the answer is yes.
So if you use
Bayes' formula, you
can see that you can define
an implicit classifier,
so called p of y given x
based on the generation,
like the unconditioned
generation of your image
and the conditioned
generation of your image,
so conditioned on y.
Which means that if
you have a network that
can generate an image
without any conditions
and that can generate an
image with a given condition,
then you can solve this problem
by plugging this equation
back into what we had,
which is what we do here.
So the equation that
I showed regarding
the distribution of
the next sampling step
can be written in epsilon space.
So I mentioned this Gaussian
distribution of shifted mean.
You can rewrite
the noise that you
want to predict into one
that takes into account
that classifier signal.
And what the
authors of the paper
of the classifier free
guidance paper did
is that they plugged
in the P phi.
Expression with the
implicit classifier,
the expression that I
just mentioned before.
And they obtained this
very nice expression
that is a function
of the noise that we
want to remove based on a model
that isn't fed any condition,
and one for which a
condition is provided.
And what you can
see is that there
is this w term in
the middle that
has about the same
interpretation as the one
that we saw before that
will tweak the generation
to be more or less towards
the condition that you bring.
So there's that.
And then now, we are
happy because we no longer
have to train separate
classifier phi.
We can just rely on the
generation network's weights.
So how does that look
like in practice?
So with a certain
probability called
the unconditional
probability, what
you can do is sample an image
from your training set, and time
step, and noise, and try to
predict the noise from it,
which is what we
saw in the past.
And with probability 1 minus p
unconditional, what you can do
is do the same.
But then use the embeddings
that we saw in the parts
just before to feed that network
with this additional information
and predict the
quantity of noise
to remove with the condition y.
So you do that 1 minus
p and conditional times.
And what you get is
something interesting,
which is if you look at how
your predictions look like,
so let's say the noise
that you want to remove
is the points top left,
and then the noise that you
want to remove when
you have a condition
is the one in the middle.
Then the guidance
hyperparameter w
will push the
prediction of the noise
more towards the noise
of the condition sample.
And the reason why we
do that is that because
in practice, if you don't have
this hyperparameter, you tend.
And if you just use the
condition sample noise
as the one that you use to
denoise your noisy latents,
you might obtain images that
do not follow your prompts very
closely.
And this is why we have
such a hyperparameter
in the first place.
In terms of numbers, the
guidance parameter is typically
set to just a few,
I think three.
In the paper, so
typically more than one.
And I just want to
put a disclaimer here
that the equations that I showed
with the classifier guidance
hyperparameter might
have several definitions.
So you might see formulas
with w in there, w plus 1.
So all these values
of w that you take
are dependent on the equation
that you operate from.
So this is 1.
And then the other thing
is that in practice
at training time, the
proportion of time for which you
show unconditioned generation
is typically 10%, 20% of time.
And this time, you
do not need to have
an additional classifier
at hand and to do
an expensive backward pass.
But you still need to
do two inference steps.
Because we saw that the
equation has this epsilon
theta of xt and no condition,
and the one with the condition
which is 2 forward passes.
So you still have
some extra cost,
although it's better
than the other technique.
And this technique, CFG is the
one that's most used today.
OK.
So any questions?
OK, great.
With that, I hope you
have a great weekend.
[APPLAUSE]